und wir legen direkt mal los zum
warmwerden mit einer hammer meldung aus
dieser woche weiß nicht ob sie das
mitgekriegt haben eine vertraute der
bundeskanzlerin lässt sich in der bild
zeitung zitieren mit den worten angela
merkel wählt nur noch termine und themen
aus die ihr freude machen
warum auch nicht weil damen und herren
es ist doch schön
ich finde sie hat sich das verdient und
offensichtlich ist das einzige was der
frau heutzutage noch spaß macht
außenpolitik also ja einfach mal weg aus
der verarmten wurde hier ne beim japan
besuch anfang der woche hat man diese
neue entspanntheit bei merkel auch
direkt gesehen ich finde sogar jetzt bei
allem respekt sie lässt sich so ein
bisschen gehen oder wenn man genau aber
ich wünschte das ist ja warum wir milch
kommen also im grunde im sinne von für
japan reicht ja nochmal ich kann sie
verstehen wirklich außenpolitik ist im
vergleich einfach viel geiler
da musste auch nicht jedes wort auf die
goldwaage legen und laberst einfach
irgendwas wussten sie dass hier schon
deutschland und japan hingegen sehr weit
auseinander
aber im kern ist nur einmal russland
dazwischen
[Musik]
das letzte mal als nur russland zwischen
deutschland und japan lag war glaube ich
1941 aber egal
während sich also unsere kanzlerin
endgültig raus hält aus den dreckigen
niederungen der innenpolitik streitet
ihre arme woco zu hause über die
sogenannte respekt rente die respekt
rente oder wie experten sie nennen das
zahnlose grundeinkommen ja ja rente
wissen sie ist ja ein ganz schwieriges
thema wo wirklich nur noch die experten
durchblicken erfülle die grundrente
klingt eigentlich gut wie sehen sie ich
finde die auch gut ist doch gut
ja ist wirklich gut war gegen die
sauerei dass menschen in deutschland
jahrzehnte malochen aber am ende genauso
viel kriegen wie einer der nie
gearbeitet hat hätte man schon längst
was machen müssen seit jahren arbeiten
die dran wird bei uns alles mit der
stütze verrechnet ungerechterweise aber
gut das machen ja wahrscheinlich alles
ohne bitte ich alle in deutschland ist
es so wer weniger einzahlt kriegt wenig
raus und wer wenig einzahlen kann ist
dazu verdammt ein armer rentner zu
werden das ist in fast allen anderen
europäischen ländern nicht so ist
eigentlich nur noch in mexiko so da sind
wir doch in bester gesellschaft oder
rente im po mexiko sage ich nur ja
wer das problem altersarmut ernsthaft
angehen will muss endlich was machen
gegen den ausufernden niedriglohnsektor
bei uns aber immerhin so immer das
positive die spd nicht völlig verkehrt
problem am selben wochenende am selben
wochenende sagt erst der
spd-finanzminister olaf scholz spitzname
die rote null wissen sie er habe da
plötzlich ein finanzloch gefunden und
wir müssten jetzt leider sparen und dann
sagt sein genosse spd sozialminister
heil
ich brauche mal eben fünf bis zehn
milliarden für eine respekt rente ja wie
denn jetzt das thema rente geht doch
alle an
und gerade die jungen wollen antworten
den brennt das thema regelrecht auf den
nägeln
damit wir die weichen auch über 2025
hinaus stellen können diese
bundesregierung ist entschlossen das
machen wir mit dem rentenbericht
deutlich dass wir einen verlässlichen
generationenvertrag organisieren ja
kommen
das ist kein vorwurf jetzt meine wenn
hubertus heil redet schon jetzt sogar
der bundesadler ein aber tatsächlich hat
seinen rentenkonzept ein paar
schönheitsfehler haben sie
wahrscheinlich gelesen über die fehlende
bedürftigkeitsprüfung zum beispiel kann
man sicher streiten
stichwort gießkanne aber manche
argumente gegen seine respekt rente
wirken schon ein bisschen konstruiert
derjenige der eine kleine rente hat aber
einen ehegatten mit einer hohen pension
oder eine kleine rente und 5 millionen
euro geerbt der braucht keine
zusätzliche leistung von herrn heil
das ist nämlich das problem ja diese
vielen bedürftigen rentner die fünf
millionen geerbt haben
totale pesto verstopfen die
fußgängerzone aber zurück zur respekt
rente des genossen heil ich spoiler
jetzt mal was am ende kommt die so
natürlich nicht nicht in dieser gruppe
genauso wenig wie die zwölf euro
mindestlohn die sie neuerlich gefordert
haben wie kann man in menschen den immer
nur kurz hoffnung machen
die spd redet wirklich nur noch mit sich
selber was man den sozen allerdings
lassen muss ihre gesetze haben jetzt
achten sie mal darauf immer so schön im
griffigen namen
ich finde geradezu kindgerecht hits
kennt ihr die spd wir machen die
tollsten gesetze das gute kita gesetz
das haben wir extra sogenannt damit auch
du merkst dass das gut ist du kleiner
jovi oder das starke familiengesetz das
ist voll stark sagte schon der name und
jetzt kommt auch noch die respekt rente
im sinne von respekt wer davon leben
kann ehrlich hätten wir gewusst dass es
so einfach ist hätten wir unsere blüten
hartz 4 gesetzte damals einfach anders
genannt zb dass papa ist jetzt ganz viel
zu hause gesetz und das beste an der spd
für unser nächstes wahlergebnis musst du
nur die zahlen bis 9 kennen spd
ja
[Applaus]
die zeit ist
die zahlen bis 9 ich wünschte das wäre
ein witz spd in bayern aktuell bei 6
prozent
übermorgen treffen sie sich zur klausur
in berlin um eine neue sozialpolitik zu
sagen wir mal beschließen
im grunde müsste man der spd echt helfen
ernsthaft also ich nicht natürlich aber
gernot hassknecht
januar täglich rettet die spd in nur 108
10 sekunden
hallo mein name ist gernot und ich habe
mehrfach spd gewählt aber das kann man
erklären
ich bin als kind einfach wahnsinnig auch
vom wickeltisch gefallen war ein gott
genossen reißt euch zusammen sonst ist
die alte tante spd bald die kalte tante
spd hört auf euch gegenseitig zu
zerfleischen jetzt meldet sich im
spiegel dieser völlig verwahrloste
erdgas vertreter zu wort
ausgerechnet der typ der die spd in die
scheiße geritten hat war es jetzt wie
man wieder rauskommt und empfiehlt
seiner partei ein frisches junges talent
zitat sigmar gabriel ist vielleicht der
bekannteste politiker den wir in der spd
haben
[Gelächter]
und das schlimme ist das stimmt warum
erklären jetzt andrea und olaf sie
trauen sich kannst dazu hat überhaupt
keiner gefragt von euch wird in den
nächsten 50 jahren keiner kanzler es sei
denn alle anderen parteien denen
verboten
ach spd am wochenende plant ihr also den
neuen sozialstaat mit vielen tollen
ideen hat vier weg kindergrundsicherung
schreibt man alles auf was euch so
einfällt und dann nimmt ihr das papier
das fertige und es direkt das pro
nichts davon bekommen in einer regierung
merkel und die bürger wissen dass nur
zwei sachen können euch noch retten
erstens endlich raus aus der coco und
zweitens stellt gerd schröder ins heim
und war konsequenter weise in ein
russisches
[Applaus]
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen ihre texte kritiken liegen
und hier last jetzt dass felix ein
beschissenes autobahn
[Musik]